[Music]
foreign
I started in Colombia and from there I
went through the Darian jungle then we
went to Panama and from Panama to Costa
Rica and so on until we reached Mexico
and the United States I started with
three friends Andres Joanne and Willie
[Music]
dynamism
we started through some Ravines followed
by a climb and the climb lasted about
five hours then we reached the Columbia
Panama border and began to descend it
was like four or five hours going down a
lot more difficult in the mud there were
a ton of people along the way we got to
bahuchikito there we were waiting to get
on a boat but because there was a lot of
people and congestion we went walking
instead
[Music]
since we had little money it was harder
because if you want to catch a bus you
can't because there's no money if you
want to eat you can't because there's no
money same goes for water and it
complicates everything there were
obstacles that I've never experienced
before so we had to be mentally strong
[Music]
it's a difficult thing I've never seen a
train before and so that was the first
time seeing one the famous La Bestia and
the first night was very cold it was
very cold we didn't come well prepared
for that people help out along the way
they throw things at you and they can
provide food and water and things like
that it was a cool and yet very powerful
experience
[Music]
thank you
I was only in a shelter for five days
and they let me pass over to this side
everyone has their own way of seeing
things but thank God I didn't suffer too
much